und jetzt das heute journal
nein zum krieg nein zum russischen
angriff auf die ukraine das wollen sie
ganz klar machen zu abertausenden
vielleicht eine halbe million allein in
berlin und mehr in vielen anderen
städten
vor der tür ein fahnenmeer in blau und
gelb und innen im deutschen parlament
stehende ovationen für den botschafter
der ukraine
eine umarmung
und milliarden für die bundeswehr in
einer neuen welt
ob wladimir putin all das mit
einkalkuliert hat vielleicht sein ziel
kann es nicht gewesen sein guten abend
in allen am ende einer woche die unsere
welt heftig erschüttert ganz unmittelbar
die der menschen in der ukraine die um
ihr leben bangen aber auch unsere welt
hier das hat sich heute im bundestag
gezeigt in der atemberaubenden weise die
jahrzehntealte polit positionen
abgeräumt wurden da kann neues entstehen
jetzt entsteht erst mal große
unsicherheit wir beginnen mit zwei
großen entwicklungen es soll direkte
verhandlungen geben zwischen der ukraine
und russland aber es gibt auch eine
drohung aus dem kreml präsident putin
versetzt die abschreckungs waffen seiner
atommacht in alarmbereitschaft
die lage heute abend von christa von
rechenberg
es ist die nächste eskalation aus moskau
putin reagiert auf die sanktionen des
westens nennt sie illegal zudem sagt er
würden sich spitzenvertreter führen der
nato-staaten aggressive töne erlauben
deshalb befehle ich dem
verteidigungsminister und den
generalstabschef die nuklearen
abschreckungskräfte der russischen armee
in höchste kampfbereitschaft zu
versetzen
im luftraum über der nato ostflanke
erhöhte aktivität tankflugzeuge
aufklärer auf russischer seite ebenfalls
aufklärer in der luft das video nicht
mehr infiziert kurz nach putin meldet
sich der ukrainische präsident er stimmt
verhandlungen mit russland zu dessen
delegation wartete bereits in minsk
setzte ein ultimatum
doch die ukraine wollte nicht in belarus
verhandeln nun lenkt sie ein
die russische und die ukrainische
delegation werden sich an der grenze
treffen und zwar ohne vorbedingungen
allerdings ich verspreche mir von dem
treffen nicht viel schauen wir was sie
anzubieten haben
mittlerweile hat die gesamte eu ihren
luftraum für russische flugzeuge
gesperrt alle müssen ausweichen chaos am
himmel
kiew hat eine weitere horror nacht
hinter sich am horizont die flammen
eines brennenden öl lagers hier soll
eine russische rakete eingeschlagen
seien und wieder soll es angriffe auf
zivile ziele gegeben haben am tag
luftalarm schüsse explosionen
ausgangssperre die stadt ist
menschenleer ihre bewohner suchen schutz
in der tiefe am abend hieß es kiew sei
umstellt niemand komme mehr raus
offenbar hat bürgermeister klitschko
dies aber wieder dementiert
ich bin stolz auf unsere armee auf
unsere ukraine die unsere stadt
verteidigen unser zuhause unsere familie
und
klare meldungen kommen aus chef der
zweitgrößten stadt des landes am frühen
morgen sprengenden russische soldaten
eine pipeline in die luft bringen
anschließend offenbar ins zentrum vor
die bilder nicht vollständig
verifizierbar sollen russische soldaten
in der stadt zeigen kämpfen plündern und
ukrainische soldaten beim gegenangriff
angeblicher ein gestoppter militärkonvoi
angeblich sei die stadt wieder unter
ukrainischer kontrolle
es läuft nicht reibungslos für putins
armee die führung gibt heute erstmals
verluste zu und das netz ist voll von
mutmaßlich zurückgelassenen fahrzeugen
überrumpelten einheiten einige fehler
essen anderen der sprit überprüft auch
diese bilder nicht
das kinderkrankenhaus von charkiw eilig
evakuiert und umgezogen in einem bunker
putin hat seine militärischen ziele noch
nicht erreicht nur dass menschen in
angst und auf der flucht mehr als
300.000 sollen schon die eu erreicht
haben die hilfsbereitschaft dort sei
gewaltig und in russland demonstrieren
auch heute einige mutige für frieden am
tag vier des krieges
das war die übersicht jetzt gehen wir
hin die details eilmeldungen wie es sie
heute gab sind ja das wirklich
allerletzte was man lesen will putin
versetzt russische atom streitkräfte in
alarmbereitschaft hieß es da umso
wichtiger ist es all das einzuordnen und
das machen wir jetzt mit den beiden
polen moskau und washington und danach
mit einem ehemaligen nato befehlshaber
zunächst nach moskau wie christian weise
so etwas muss man ja genau auch zwischen
den zeilen lesen was genau hat gut
hinein in die welt gesetzt
putin hat das heute gesagt bei einem
treffen mit hochrangigen militärs das
wurde dann auch hier live im fernsehen
übertragen und er begründet das mit den
harten wirtschaftssanktionen gegen
russland und die ganze zeit wenn es um
das thema sanktionen hier gingen hieß es
ja mal das können wir irgendwie abfedern
das ist eingepreist aber dass die
sanktionen jetzt so schnell kommen und
teilweise auch hart sind damit hat putin
vielleicht dann doch nicht gerechnet und
deswegen jetzt diese massive drohungen
wer hat denn den zugriff auf die
russischen atomwaffen ist das nur putin
selbst
also es gibt hier in russland drei atom
koffer einer ist beim präsidenten also
bei putin der anderen bei gutem
verteidigungsminister guter freund von
putin die beiden gehen ja gerne auch mal
zusammen jagen in sibirien und der
dritte beim chef des generalstabs und um
die waffen aus zu lösen braucht man zwei
dieser koffer und die codes dafür die
sind bei den generälen russland hat
diese waffen und putin weiß dass er der
welt damit angst machen kann aber nicht
nur der welt sondern auch den russinnen
und russen selbst ich habe gerade eben
noch mal mit einem russischen freund
hier gesprochen ihnen die frage was er
denn über das denkt und er sagt putin
zerstört die reputation russlands
unserer heimat für die nächsten 20 bis
30 jahre und niemand kann uns helfen
weiter nach washington claudia bertz
zurück in den dunkelsten tage des kalten
krieges wähnt man sich da heute ganz
plötzlich wie kam denn das im weißen
haus an
präsident biden ist zu hause in delaware
auf einer privaten veranstaltung und hat
sich noch nicht selber geäußert ist aber
mit seinem nationalen sicherheitsrat in
engem kontakt und es wird hier jetzt
erst mal geschaut und analysiert was
denn dieser schritt putins praktisch
eigentlich bedeutet beiden sprecherin
jenny sagte das ist eigentlich das
bekannte muster von putin er konstruiert
eine bedrohung die es gar nicht gibt um
dann eben mit einer eskalation darauf zu
reagieren und diese eskalation damit zu
rechtfertigen man wisse sich zu
verteidigen und die us botschafterin bei
den vereinten nationen linda thomas
greenfield hat russland aufgefordert die
aggressive rhetorik zu entschärfen und
sprach auch von einer eskalation aus
verschiedenen quellen hören wir es
könnte sein dass es neue sanktionen
geben wird diesmal gegen den
energie-sektor claudia vielleicht noch
ganz kurz wie ist denn die vorgesehene
amerikanische vorgehensweise jetzt in so
einem fall sprechen jetzt die militärs
beider seiten erst mal miteinander
sprechen die überhaupt miteinander
also die usa haben immer natürlich
betonte dass der diplomatische weg der
wichtigste ist gleichzeitig ist die
frage was soll die grundlage jetzt
solcher gespräche sein denn es gibt hier
auch eine klare
eskalationsstufe bei der beim militär
das heißt was passiert dort jetzt wird
beiden die truppen hier auch in
alarmbereitschaft versetzen oder nicht
das ist alles ganz klar geregelt stufe 1
bis 5 von eben friedenszeiten bis einem
kurz bevorstehenden nuklearkrieg und nun
müssen wir sehen wo beiden diesen
schritt putins jetzt einordnet und was
er dann selber daraus für schlüsse zieht
für sein militär ok claudia herzlichen
dank für den moment joe biden bei einem
privaten termin in delaware vielleicht
ist das ja ein gutes zeichen heute abend
an diesem so aufführen den tag
herzlichen dank nach moskau und nach
washington und jetzt gucken wir auf das
ganze aus der sicht eines
militärexperten und zwar des
ranghöchsten ehemaligen ranghöchsten
deutschen nato befehlshabers general
egon ramms der general willkommen zurück
im heute-journal
guten alten silos wie oft passiert dass
aus ihrer erfahrung dass russland damit
droht atomstreitkräfte werden jetzt in
alarmbereitschaft versetzt das letzte
mal war das im jahr 2014 aus die wussten
die kollektive haben auch da hat sich
die hatten sich die nuklear streitkräfte
in der jetzigen alarmstufe gefunden die
als ergänzung zu dem was aus washington
gesagt worden ist vier stufen mit
hochgefahren wird sie befinden sich
ganze stufe 2 das heisst raul 4 sind
noch nicht ausgenutzt okay das heißt da
ist noch luft nach oben zum glück muss
man ja sagen wie hoch würden sie denn
die gefahr jetzt einschätzen dass bei
alledem was ich da gerade hochschaukelt
etwas furchtbares schief läuft es
einfach missverständnisse gibt
also diese gefahr ist sicherlich gegeben
weil ich hoffe ihr korrespondent aus
moskau hatte die drei koffer dies drei
koffer prinzip gerade beschrieben dass
dieses prinzip dass man mindestens zwei
koffer braucht um diese waffen
auszulösen entsprechend greift von daher
ist immer eine kontrollfunktion drin
wobei ich auch betonen dass ein
korrespondent hat mit der aus recht hat
mit der aussage dass er sagt der
verteidigungsminister ist ein ergebnis
mitarbeiter die
gucken wir noch kurz auf deutschland auf
unsere armee her wir haben vor ein paar
tagen vorgestern war es glaube ich
miteinander geredet und sie sagten auf
die frage ob die bundeswehr in der lage
sei deutschland zu verteidigen nein ein
klares nein das war in ihre worte jetzt
wird es eine neue bundeswehr geben 100
milliarden zusätzlich sind heute
angekündigt das klingt wie eine riesige
summe das ist auch eine riesige summe
ist es für die bundeswehr aus ihrer
sicht ein entscheidender schritt
oder der entscheidende schritt liegt
darin dass dieses geld offensichtlich
noch im haushalt
2022 zumindest in teilen zur verfügung
gestellt werden soll um das damit
beschaffungsvorhaben ihre letzten
legislaturperiode nicht mehr
verwirklicht werden konnten oder nicht
mehr verwirklicht wurden aufgrund
welcher um diese entscheidung auch immer
jetzt wieder angeschoben werden können
wobei ich auch darauf hinweisen möchte
dass es für mich in erster priorität
wichtig ist neben den großen
beschaffungsvorhaben für die ausrüstung
und ausstattung der soldaten zu sorgen
und dafür zu sorgen dass die bundeswehr
wieder mit allen verbänden
vollausgestattet einsatz bereitstellen
wird auch das kostet zeit aber es wird
mit diesen mitteln deutlich schneller
gehen als es vorher mit dem
haushaltsansatz möglich gewesen wäre das
kostet zeit irgendjemand hat geschrieben
die bundeswehr habe aktuell die
beweglichkeit einer wanderdüne wie
schnell geht denn das jetzt das hängt
davon ab was man vorhat also wenn man
vorhat neue waffensysteme zu kaufen bei
nato partnern beispielsweise bei den
amerikanern um diese waffensysteme sind
fertig dann kann man sich relativ
schnell beschaffen ich nehme als
beispiel dafür den schweren
transporthubschrauber da stand man im
letzten jahr vor einer entscheidung die
entscheidung ist nicht mehr getroffen
worden sie könnte jetzt sofort
unverzüglich getroffen werden und dann
könnte man relativ schnell mit der
auslieferung von der stückzahl her würde
ich mal sagen drei bis vier jahre dieses
manko ersetzen und die ca 53 ausnahme
ein anderes waffensystem bis heute auch
im gespräch gewesen ist oder die f35 vom
kanzler selber erwähnt das dürfte nicht
ganz so schnell gehen weil davon keine
waffensysteme zurzeit verfügbar sind und
bei werden wir die waffensysteme haben
auch diese erstmal bei uns eingeführt
werden müssen und dann auch die piloten
der satzung entsprechend ausgebildet
werden general egon ramms auch heute
abend wieder herzlichen dank für ihre
expertise bei uns gerne herzlichen dank
und damit sind wir bei dem was dieser
tag gezeigt hatte in der deutschen
politik und zwar über weite teile des
bundestages hinweg spd und grüne und fdp
und cdu und csu dieses land wird sich
ändern und zwar deutlich britta
spiekermann
es ist dieser eine moment der
ukrainische botschafter bedankt sich
beim parlament bei der regierung für
soviel stehenden applaus für so viel
solidarität
es ist dieser eine moment als der
frühere bundespräsident gauck gar nicht
mehr anders kann als seine arme
auszubreiten
diese sondersitzung des bundestages ist
in jeglicher hinsicht besonders es geht
um das leid des ukrainischen volkes um
die skrupellosigkeit putins es geht um
eine wie scholz sagt klare deutsche
antwort auf die neue realität
viele von uns haben noch die erzählung
unserer eltern oder großeltern immer vom
krieg
und für die jüngeren ist es kaum fassbar
krieg in europa wir erleben eine
zeitenwende
und das bedeutet die welt danach
ist nicht mehr dieselbe wie die welt
davor
im kern geht es um die frage ob macht
das recht brechen darf ob wir es putin
gestatten die uhren zurückzudrehen in
die zeit der großmächte des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts oder ob wir die kraft
aufbringen kriegstreibern wie putin
grenzen zu setzen
es ist das ende des zögerns das ende der
deutschen zurückhaltung
wie sie wissen haben wir gestern
entschieden dass deutschland der ukraine
waffen zur verteidigung des landes
liefern wird
auf googles aggression konnte es keine
antwort antwort geben vor wenigen wochen
noch habe ich hier in diesen sei zum
thema waffenlieferungen gesagt dass man
seine außenpolitische
180 grad wendung im richtigen moment und
bei vollem bewusstsein treffen muss
jetzt ist so traurig es ist der moment
dafür
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine und
auch die bundeswehr soll aufgerüstet
werden mit einem sondervermögen von 100
milliarden euro die union will den kurs
der regierung im prinzip unterstützen
besonders mit blick auf die sanktionen
russland wird international isoliert das
land und seine repräsentanten werden
auch persönlich sanktioniert dazu gehört
damit dass hier kreist auch von meiner
seite richtigerweise swift das
internationale zahlungssystem mit dem
jetzt russland aus dem internationalen
zahlungsverkehr ausgeschlossen wird
diese sanktionen werden negative
auswirkungen auch auf uns haben aber wir
sind bereit diese negativen auswirkungen
zu tragen denn sie sind der preis der
freiheit immer wieder stehender applaus
und während der debatte nur die afg
bleibt durch die bank sitzen schuld am
angriffskrieg russland trage auch der
westen es war ein verhängnisvoller
fehler die ukraine mit den unerfüllbaren
versprechen einer mitgliedschaft in nato
und eu in eine aussichtslose
konfrontation und eine gefährliche
zerreißprobe zu locken was haben wir
hier gerade gehört
was für ein bild der gründe warum es zu
diesem krieg gekommen ist
sagen wir es in aller klarheit
putin hat die ukraine angegriffen weil
sich ein souveräner staat
in freier selbstbestimmung
dafür entschieden hat seinen weg nach
westen zu gehen
scholz versucht für deutschland eine
neue rolle zu finden in einer auf den
kopf gestellten europäischen
friedensordnung seine wohl beste rede
ich danke all in diesen tagen zeichen
setzen gegen putins krieg und die sich
hier in berlin und anderswo zu
friedlichen kundgebung versammeln
und ich danke allen die in diesen zeiten
mit uns einstehen für ein freies und
offenes gerechtes und friedliches europa
wir werden das verteidigen
es ist ein versprechen alle anwesenden
wissen es steht viel auf dem spiel
politik ist langsam weg tab politische
positionen entwickeln sich manchmal über
jahrzehnte das hat viele gute seiten
eine berechenbare berechtigung heute ist
alles anders robert habeck von den
grünen ist der vizekanzler habe guten
abend du wirst nicht grüße sie als wären
alle plötzlich aus einem traum erwacht
und in der realität angekommen die sich
als hochgefährlich erweist es ist ein
paar monate erst her da wollten sie
waffenlieferungen in die ost ukraine
haben einen shitstorm geerntet auch in
der eigenen partei mussten heftig
zurückrudern können sich daran noch
erinnern ja
und jetzt sagen sie heute im deutschen
bundestag ich zitiere mal wer weiß wie
sich dieser krieg entwickeln wird und ob
aus dieser entscheidung heraus nicht
weitere entscheidungen getroffen werden
müssen und wir irgendwann lauter waffen
liefern für einen dauerhaften land krieg
in europa zitat ende herr beck
war das eine schocktherapie heute
die letzten wochen insgesamt waren ich
würde nicht sagen schocktherapie weil
das ja bedeutet dass man davor quasi in
einem krankhaften zustand war und
geheilt werden musste und man sollte
doch eher umgekehrt sagen dass der
zustand davor auch mit einem ihre
aufrüsten in russland aber immerhin
einen frieden der normalzustand sein
sollte aber dass sich die wirklichkeit
dramatisch geändert hat das konnten wir
seit weihnachten beobachten wenn sie
jetzt heute hören russland versetzt
seine atomstreitkräfte in
alarmbereitschaft was löst das bei ihnen
aus ja sage also immer noch ist es
unvorstellbar dass das immer weiter geht
dass deutschland die nato-staaten in
einem bewaffneten konflikt direkt rein
gezogen werden aber es sei eben auch bis
vor kurzem und vorstellbar dass putin
massiv die ukraine angreifen und
überrollt also es gibt größten grund für
politische anstrengungen die diplomatie
wieder am leben zu erhalten oder zum
leben zu bringen
sanktionen sind die eine sache sind
sicher wichtig aber entgleitet uns
gerade alles
nein das ist anders es gibt auch die
verabredung dass sich ukrainische und
russische diplomaten an der bille
russischen grenze treffen ebenfalls
heute abend und meiner wahrnehmung nach
findet der westen findet die allianz
findet deutschland mit den partnern
endlich zu einer entschlossenheit die
davor teilweise fehlte also insofern ist
es kein entgleiten sondern ein fester
zupacken der bundeskanzler hat vor ein
paar tagen noch gesagt wir brauchen auch
eskalationsspirale einfach für den für
den für die möglichkeit dass die ganze
lage eskaliert jetzt ist sie so schnell
eskaliert dass wir zumindest rhetorisch
bereits bei atomwaffen sind wie bekommen
wir das denn wieder gestoppt und
gleichzeitig deutlich gemacht dass putin
so nicht weitermachen kann
also die atomwaffen hat putin ins spiel
gebracht und nicht der deutsche
bundeskanzler und niemand aus der
bundesregierung das wird auch nicht
passieren
die das beste szenario ist dass die
gegenwehr der ukraine unterstützt auch
jetzt durch die waffen von verschiedenen
ländern westeuropas und der amerikaner
in der lage sind putin an den
verhandlungstisch zu zwingen das ist das
beste szenario
und die chancen dafür
liegen und das ist so bitter weil ich zu
sagen auf dem schlachtfeld der ukraine
wenn die ukraine
es ist so mann gehabt historische
parallelen ja auch in russland gezogen
und
als der afghanistan-krieg an dem
russland beteiligt war immer blutiger
wurde als das komitee der soldatenmütter
auf die straße gegangen sind als die
proteste damals in der sowjetunion immer
lauter geworden sind hat das seinen
beitrag geleistet zur destabilisierung
der sowjetunion nicht alleine
selbstverständlich aber schon einen
erheblichen wenn putin also fürchten
muss dass der widerstand im eigenem land
zu groß wird dann wird er umkehren und
so sind die sanktionen ja auch
ausgerichtet dass auch die menschen um
ihn herum die oligarchen die clique um
ihn herum so hart getroffen werden dass
sie im eigenen lager hoffentlich und
möglicherweise sagen so geht es nicht
weiter da haben wir einen fehler gemacht
wir suchen wir nach einer
gesichtswahrenden lösung da rauszukommen
beides zusammen kann der weg zum
verhandlungstisch sein gucken wir nach
deutschland der hupac sie sind ja auch
wirtschaftsminister energieminister sie
haben gesagt die energieversorgung ist
eine frage der nationalen sicherheit das
spüren wir alle gerade sehr deutlich auf
der anderen seite merken wir aber auch
wir haben von allem zu wenig zu wenig
alternativen zu wenig neue energien zu
wenig logistik zu wenig in den speichern
können sie deutschland wirklich
beruhigen in dieser lage
in dieser lage ja wir kommen mit den
gasvorräten die wir ohne groß darüber zu
reden seit weihnachten aufgestockt haben
über den winter und über den sommer für
den nächsten winter müssen wir die käufe
deutlich erhöhen wir kommen mit der
reserve sowie so gut durch da gibt es
das noch eine nationale reserve die über
drei monate ausreicht und es gibt
anstrengungen auch kohlereserven zu
schaffen also für die lage ja
langfristig oder mittelfristig mit blick
auf den nächsten winter müssen wir
unsere anstrengungen unabhängiger von
russischen von russischen importen zu
werden noch deutlich erhöhen um wirklich
sicher zu sein und wir müssen vor allem
die verbrennung von fossilen energien
die dann ja immer ungefähr zur hälfte
mit russischen importen befriedet werden
möglichst schnell reduzieren und
entsprechend auch schnell vorschläge
dafür ausarbeiten und das werde ich tun
und dann werden wir schauen ob all die
sonntagsreden auch zutaten
langfristig sagen sie so weit ist der
nächste winter nicht mehr entfernt
robert habeck der vizekanzler herzlichen
dank für das gespräch heute abend nicht
da gehen
und das haben wir vor etwa einer stunde
aufgezeichnet wir berichten noch
ausführlich weiter gehen gleich live in
die ukraine auch live nach kiew wo sich
die lage offenbar zuspitzt und wir
gucken natürlich auf die bedrückende
situation von hunderttausenden die
fliehen müssen erst ein kommentar über
diesen denkwürdigen moment auch für die
deutsche politik hier ist heute journal
redaktionsleiter wolf schließe
deutschland hat das endlich begriffen
putins angriffe auf die ukraine gilt
auch uns er richtet sich gegen die
freiheit in ganz europa noch nie waren
auch wir so bedroht wie jetzt zwischen
deutschland und der ukraine liegen
weniger kilometer als zwischen hamburg
und münchen olaf scholz könnte schon
bald zum kriegs kanzler werden heute ist
er zunächst zum abschreckungs kanzler
geworden mit seiner ankündigung den
wehretat zu verdreifachen
das fällt dem früheren finanzminister
reichlich spät ein und hilft akut wohl
kaum aber es ist eine 180 grad wende in
der russland politik der spd wandel
durch handel kann es mit putin nicht
mehr geben denn der ist skrupellos und
als herrscher über atomwaffen eine
gefahr für die ganze welt dieser
ebenfalls viel zu späten erkenntnis
wagen nun selbst die schwesigs platz
sechs und stegners nicht mehr zu
widersprechen obwohl sie putin noch bis
vor wenigen tagen verharmlost haben
einzig sein hoch bezahlter lobbyist
gerhard schröder will sich immer noch
nicht vom russischen diktator lossagen
und nimmt für das viele geld in kauf
dass seine partei sich nun doch noch
beschämt abwendet alles sanktions pulver
ist nun weitgehend verschossen es wird
russland treffen aber auch jeden von uns
wenn das gas nicht mehr fließt und die
preise hoch schießen die ampel regierung
muss deutschland auf einen langen teuren
und sehr bitteren weg einstellen die
nato ist jetzt eine echte
schicksalsgemeinschaft
größtmögliche abschreckung ist die
letzte hoffnung für unseren frieden
dafür brauchen wir die usa und die
hatten die ganze zeit recht mit ihrer
warnung investiert mehr ins militär und
vertraut niemals auf putin
wulf schmiese kommentierte unternehmen
wir sie jetzt mit auf die straßen der
ukraine wo sich zwischendurch
erstaunliches abspielt es gibt eine
ganze reihe von videos die geradezu
grotesken momente wieder geben die
ukrainische autofahrer auf russlands
panzer am straßenrand treffen
[Musik]
ein paar sekunden nur eine sehr reale
situation diana zimmermann server 1 fort
und linz um jetzt mit mehr aus dem
südosten der ukraine
gerade haben in diesem studentenwohnheim
in depot noch junge menschen mit einer
zukunft gewohnt nun ist es ein heim für
flüchtlinge aus dem osten des landes
sowie nadeshda und ihre familie
wir schämen uns um hilfe zu bitten und
das beunruhigendste ist dass wir nicht
wissen wie lange es dauern wird und ob
es irgendetwas geben wird zudem wir
zurückkehren können
videos von zu hause zeigen wofür sie
ihre familie in sicherheit gebracht hat
andere flüchtlinge werden heute hier auf
dem boden einer konzerthalle übernachten
putin sagt der verteidiger uns aber vor
wem vor uns selbst indem er unsere
häuser und unser land niederbrennt
momentan ist es hier noch ruhig aber
mein herz ist gebrochen
meine familie auseinander gezerrt und
ich habe angst um meine kinder ich
möchte nur dass dieser albtraum aufhört
und
zwar mit einem anderen ende als dem dass
moskau sich ausgedacht hat daran
arbeitet auch ein ukrainischer extrem
jeder seinen bürgern per video erklärt
wie man molotow-cocktails macht
auf dem marktplatz von mir wissen sie es
schon und treffen sich auch heute zur
traurigen bastelstunde das styropor das
in die flaschen wandert stammt teilweise
aus maxim's tonstudio
unsere generation der alle haben
geschichten gehört von unseren
großvätern die den narzissmus bekämpft
haben wie märchen über die man gelächelt
hat aber jetzt sind wir wie unsere
großväter
die 24 jährige maria will künstlerin
werden
ich habe keine angst ich bin einfach nur
wütend
bisher hat maria sowie die meisten eher
pro überwiegend russisch gesprochen sie
gehört also zu der bevölkerungsgruppe
von der putin sagt er verteidige sie
in der ukraine wenn jetzt niemand mehr
russisch sprechen das ist jetzt die
sprache des feindes
an professionellen waffen mag es ihnen
mangeln an die entschiedenheit nicht
es sieht derzeit so aus als gälte auch
in zeiten hochgerüstete armee eine
schlichte wahrheit die eine seite hat
ein klares ziel ihr land verteidigen und
ihre freiheit den soldaten der anderen
seite scheint dieses ziel zu fehlen
unsere korrespondentin katrin eigendorf
ist im westen der ukraine kathrin guten
abend geben sie uns doch bitte mal einen
überblick soweit das möglich ist wie
steht es aktuell um die russische
invasion
also sieht so aus dass die russen wohl
wesentlich weniger schnell vorankommen
in diesem land als sie eigentlich
gedacht haben dennoch sehen wir hier
zunehmend nervosität und druck bei der
ukrainischen bevölkerung also die stadt
in der wir hier jetzt sind unser hotel
hier kommen permanent neue flüchtlinge
an menschen die einfach schnell alles
zusammen gegriffen haben mit weinenden
kindern teilweise ihre haustiere einfach
in einem käfig mit sich die hier zu
mehreren familien in einem zimmer sitzen
und dann weiterziehen viele menschen
machen sich einfach auf die flucht haben
große angst davor wie lange ihr land
hier möglicherweise belagert werden
könnte wir haben hier in der stadt auch
heute erlebt wie sich freiwillige
zusammengeschlossen haben einfach um
irgendetwas zu tun
jugendliche die hier hingehen und netze
für die front bauen pakete für soldaten
schnüren
molotow-cocktails herstellen und die
nervosität nimmt auch im prinzip hier
sehr sehr zu es ist nicht nur keys wo
diese belagerung so dramatisch spürbar
ist sondern eigentlich überall in der
ukraine hier in der stadt zum beispiel
patroullieren heute abend hier milizen
das sind im prinzip einfache bürger die
hier auf der suche sind nach möglichen
spionen russen die vielleicht hier einen
einmarsch vorbereiten könnten das
passiert in vielen städten und deswegen
können wir auch jetzt nicht mal hier auf
der straße einfach berichten das ist die
lage im land zdf korrespondentin katrin
eigendorf herzlichen dank live aus der
ukraine
eine kollegin von uns allen hier aber
jetzt auch in einem studio wie diesem
hier normalerweise jetzt ist vieles
anders sonoma wie twitter ist
nachrichtenmoderatorin bei einem
ukrainischen privatsender in kiew und
sitzt jetzt zu hause weil ausgangssperre
ist frau vivi zka guten abend
kann ich sagen abend aber nicht so gut
wie ich da haben sie das guten müssen
wir vielleicht weglassen wenn sie mal
rausgucken auf die straße wie
gespenstisch ist es da im moment wir
kriegen berichtet dass kiew umzingelt
sein soll
ist sehr dunkel und kein mensch ist
draußen und kein auto auf und ab und zu
können wir auch
liftanlagen und gehen wie in
schutzbunker oder so ist unsere pflicht
zur zeit schon vier tage das ist ihr
leben das ist das private leben aber sie
müssen ja als journalistin auch
versuchen so wahrheitsgemäß wie möglich
zu berichten im krieg heißt es zurecht
leider stirbt die wahrheit zuerst wie
kann denn ihr sender überhaupt noch
einen überblick haben über die lage in
ihrem land im moment
verschiedene sendung gehen jetzt sind
wir nicht konkurrenten sondern
arbeiten zusammen wir machen sollen 24
cent wir teilen diese zeit weil das ist
sehr schwer so machen 24
ohne
hilfe und
ich glaube das
morgen zu dass er unsere
sperrstunde ist schon weg und die ich
dann auch zu meiner arbeit hinfahren und
die studie arbeiten ja dann sondern
sondern wir überhaupt über wahrheit
sagen weil das ist sehr sehr wichtig ist
also die sender die eigentlich
miteinander in konkurrenz stehen haben
sich jetzt zusammen geschaltet machen
alle dasselbe programm auf allen sendern
wird dasselbe programm es gibt kräfte zu
bündeln frau wie wir es kann noch eine
frage was machen denn die reporter
draußen im land haben sie den eindruck
dass es da überhaupt möglich ist für sie
bilder und
überprüfbare geschichten zu finden
wir haben ganz breitere netz von unserem
wort und korrespondent und die bleiben
auch in die staaten die stadt die die
wollen und die berichte immer jede
stunde fasste
und was die sehen was
haben von den zeugen gehören und das ist
sehr wichtig weil information kriegt das
ist zweite seite von unsere zeit jetzt
ich weiß nicht wie kann das so sein dass
in weit wenn so viel informationen du
kannst fiel dann aber sowieso gibt es
irgendwelche parallel
sozusagen realität dass in russland
das sind unsere aktuellen zeiten auf
jeden fall herzlichen dank sonoma wie
witzgall herzlichen dank für das
gespräch heute live aus kiew
dankeschön für unterstützen
die reaktion der europäischen union
heute allein wäre an normalen tagen
ganze sondersendungen wert gewesen es
hat noch nie diese reaktion in diesem
umfang und in diesem ausmaß gegeben
hatte hat die exakte übersicht die eu
hat angekündigt waffen und ausrüstung
für die ukraine im wert von einer halben
milliarde euro zu finanzieren
es wäre das erste mal in der geschichte
der eu dass waffen gekauft und an ein
land geliefert werden das sich im krieg
befindet das betonte
kommissionspräsidentin von der leyen
außerdem kündigte sie neue sanktionen
gegen russland an russischen
staatsmedien brt und sputnik werden in
der eu verboten zudem wird nun der
gesamte luftraum für russische maschinen
gesperrt
mit blick auf die russischen angriffe
auf die ukraine wird morgen die
un-vollversammlung zusammentreten das
hat vor etwa einer stunde der un
sicherheitsrat beschlossen gegen den
willen russlands
ziel der angestrebten sondersitzung ist
es den russischen einmarsch in die
ukraine formell zu verurteilen das wenn
das als im un sicherheitsrat kann in der
un vollversammlung kein land ein veto
einlegen allerdings sind die
resolutionen auch nicht binden
auch gegen belarus hat die eu heute neue
sanktionen wegen des ukrainisch kriegs
beschlossen soll weitere exportverbote
geben gleichzeitig wurde heute in
belarus ein umstrittenes
verfassungsreferendum
abgehalten dabei ging es unter anderem
um die amtszeit des präsidenten aber
auch um den neutralen status des landes
machthaber lukaschenko möchte dass
russische truppen und nuklearwaffen
künftig auch dauerhaft in belarus
stationiert werden können
ein kind das sich an seinen teddy bear
klammert weil auch die mutter nicht mehr
weiter weiß nach einer gefährlichen
reise quer durch ihr heimatland nach 24
stunden warten an der ukrainischen
grenze richtung westen nach dem abschied
vom vater der zurückbleiben muss um zu
kämpfen
das ist die situation nicht 100 sondern
aber tausendfach jetzt in diesem moment
europa kann nur ahnen wie viel leid da
auf dem kontinent zukommt aber europa
will seine grenzen offen halten natalie
steger ist im osten von polen britta
hilpert im osten der slowakei
josef regt das echt auf selbst an so
einem sonntag ist der supermarkt an der
grenze geschlossen die flüchtlinge
könnten sich nicht mal was kaufen also
helfen er und die nachbarn essen kaffee
tee natürlich kostenlos für die ukraine
wir sind was brüder sowie alles lagen
russen sind auf muss die meisten 90 von
ihnen oder mehr sind gute leute da ist
ein teufel und ein garten in rom
endlich auf der polnischen seite an der
grenze manche sind seit dem ersten tag
der russischen angriffe unterwegs es war
schrecklich und sehr schwierig für uns
alles aber wir haben es überlebt
die züge kommen noch durch in den
polnischen grenzort chemische katharina
und ihr sohn sind aus lewis geflogen
die katze den hund wir haben alles
schnell gepackt und dann sind wir mit
einem kleinen zug nach polen gefahren
mein älterer bruder ist geblieben er
wird kämpfen
wollte sie sicher sie haben sogar einen
autokindersitz mitgebracht die polin
agnieszka und dominica bieten fahrten
nach krakau oder kattowitz an es gibt
unzählige solcher helfer und helferinnen
das ist doch normal dass die leute
helfen und das ist alles das ist keine
große geschichte wir werden einfach
gebraucht wir müssen es machen
und sie machen es für sie die die dem
krieg in der ukraine entronnen sind
warten prägt seit vier tagen den
grenzübergang wie schon in der metzger
warten auf diesen moment
aus der ukraine kommen weiterhin vor
allem frauen kinder alte männer in die
ukraine waren nur wenige sascha ist
einer von ihnen er will kämpfen ja es
ist schwer aber ich habe schon drei
leute verloren und ich höre jetzt mein
land beschützen
wenn er zur front fährt wird er hier
vorbeikommen auf der ukrainischen seite
der grenze so zeigen webcams stehen
hunderte fußgänger und stauen sich autos
kilometer lang und das die ganze nacht
in diesem stau statt afrika sie ist
gerade mit einer gruppe angekommen im
aufnahmelager oblaten der slowakei am
freitag floh sie aus kiel
es war fürchterlich dann diese
explosionen
unsere kinder hatten natürlich stets
roman erzählt dann auch lieber von der
langen fort
dieses lange sitzen wir hatten die
schnauze voll
erst mal aus rund dafür kommen viele in
dieses aufnahmelager dann weiter auf die
familie die noch im stau steckt wartet
auch anastassia sie versteht die krieg
die russen vor allem putin nicht wir
leben doch eigentlich einander bei dem
genossen ist etwas nicht in ordnung
nur durchgangsstation ist unklar aber
auch ein erster ort des friedens
die europäische union sagt man müsse
sich auf millionen menschen vorbereiten
die fliehen könnten nancy faeser spd ist
die bundesinnenministerium von
ministerin schon guten abend
sie haben jetzt die regeln in den in
kraft gesetzt für den zitat fall eines
massenhaften zustroms von vertriebenen
das ist erstmal kein besonders hübsches
wort aber was heißt das ganz konkret
sollte das zuflucht in die eu für jede
und jeden aus der ukraine ohne
bürokratie es ist eine richtlinie die
nach dem balkan-krieg geschaffen wurde
und wir haben heute im innen rat in
brüssel mit allen innenminister ich
würde mal sagen einen richtigen
europäischen schulterschluss geschafft
indem wir gemeinsam entschieden haben
unbürokratische regeln dafür zu schaffen
dass alle ukrainischen kriegsflüchtlinge
in die eu einreisen können was heißt
denn unbürokratisch regeln das hatte ich
ja versucht herauszufinden kann quasi
jeder kommen braucht kein visum kommt
einfach rein
visumsfrei ist es das heißt es in der
tat und dann würde man einen
aufenthaltstitel erlauben bis zu einer
zeit von 3 jahren die regel ist ein jahr
kann dann unbürokratisch verlängert
werden und das erspart natürlich ein
aufwendiges asylverfahren auf jeden fall
die einheit der eu beim thema
flüchtlinge man reibt sich ein bisschen
die augen gab es ja bisher überhaupt
nicht jetzt gibt es allerdings auch
erhebliche unterschiede zu 2015 denn
viele der die da fliegen die hoffen ja
offenbar nur ein paar tage bleiben zu
müssen macht es das einfacher
ich glaube das furchtbare leid was wir
gerade sehen
das führt dazu dass wir zu dieser
einigkeit in der europäischen union
kommen ich hoffe dass davon etwas übrig
bleibt von dieser 1 darum haben wir
lange gekämpft wir wollen bei dem innen
rat der am donnerstag stattfindet auch
ein gemeinsames asylsystem schrittweise
voran bringen gemeinsam mit frankreich
und mein eindruck war heute das ist
schon historisch war ob des großen
leidest dass die europäischen staaten
heute gesagt haben wir müssen da jetzt
was unbürokratisches gemeinsames machen
immer inhalt haben sich alle dazu
verpflichtet auch kriegsflüchtlinge
aufzunehmen ok einigkeit die
möglicherweise dann auch für andere
dramatische flüchtlings schicksale
gelten möge in der zukunft frau feser es
tut sich etwas enormes wir haben
mehrfach darüber berichtet in der
deutschen politik und einen besonders
atemberaubenden weg geht ihre spd noch
vor ein paar tagen war da nicht
besonders viel druck etwa auf gerhard
schröder und jetzt wenn wir härteste
sanktionen gegen russland machen kann
dann ein ex kanzler noch auf der
gehaltsliste eines russischen
staatsunternehmens stehen ich halte das
für ausgesprochen schwierig weil ein
ehemaliger kanzler wird nie privat sein
und deswegen meine ich wäre es jetzt
angemessen dass er von seinen ämtern
zurücktritt haben sie den eindruck er
macht das bisher hat er ja überhaupt
nichts in diese richtung verlauten
lassen ich meine dass das hat der
kanzler heute gut beschrieben seit
donnerstag haben wir eine neue
zeitenwende wir haben krieg mitten in
europa und ich hoffe dass auch der
ehemalige kanzler sich deshalb auch dann
jetzt ändert jetzt war es am fünften
januar 22 in diesem jahr noch so dass
ihr staatssekretär professor gerhard
schröder getroffen hat thema war
ausgerechnet ein austausch zur situation
der zivilgesellschaft in russland wie
glaubwürdig ist denn diese kehrtwende
die wir da aktuell sehen ein
staatssekretär war der sprecher für die
deutsch-russischen beziehungen im
parlament und in dieser eigenschaft hat
er dieses gespräch noch geführt um zu
übergeben das hatte nichts mit der
aktuellen situation zu tun wenn jetzt
ausgerechnet die ministerpräsidenten von
mecklenburg vorpommern frau schwesig spd
solidarität mit der ukraine bekundet und
den landtag in blau gelb erstrahlen
sieht in schwerin dieselbe
ministerpräsidentin die noch vor ein
paar tagen die pipeline aus russland
propagiert hat gegen heftigste bedenken
der ukraine welchen beigeschmack hat das
ich finde er sie was das seit donnerstag
die welt eine andere ist wir haben einen
angriffskrieg von putin auf die ukraine
mitten in europa und das verändert
natürlich ganz ganz viel und deswegen
finde ich die reaktion aus mecklenburg
wurf vor man jetzt sehr glaubwürdig der
botschafter der ukraine war sehr
undiplomatisch und erhard ich zitiere
ihn wörtlich in richtung von
ministerpräsident in spe sich gesagt die
heuchelei ist zum kotzen
ich kann natürlich manche emotionen
gerade dieser tage verstehen gerade wenn
man botschafter eines landes ist was wo
angegriffen wird insofern kann man
glaube ich in diesen tagen da vieles
verzeihen sagt nancy faeser spd die
bundes innenministerin frau ministerin
vielen dank für das gespräch heute abend
live aus berlin gerne dankeschön
rund um die welt gibt es proteste gegen
den angriff auf die ukraine in sydney in
tokio in helsinki in moskau die
russische staatsmacht hat seit
donnerstag über 5000 menschen
festgenommen die sagen wollten dass sie
mit dem was ihr präsident da tut nicht
einverstanden sind schon das wort
invasion darf in den russischen medien
nicht mehr fallen roman leskovar hat
sich angehört was all die sagen die es
heute in deutschland auf die straße
getrieben hat
die menschen strömen in scharen zur
kundgebung am mittag
die polizei muss zeitweilig die
zugangsstraßen sperren der u bahnhof am
brandenburger tor für dicht gemacht es
ist ein eindrückliches zeichen dass an
diesem sonntag ausgesandt wird es können
auch heute noch zehntausende gegen krieg
protestieren das wahnsinn das ist eine
unterstützung also ich hätte nicht
gedacht dass so viele menschen auf die
straße geben ich fühle mich ein bisschen
glücklicher weil die welt hat die augen
aufgemacht das ist ja auch total wichtig
dass die menschen in russland
mitbekommen dass das was total schief
läuft so groß die freude über die vielen
teilnehmer so tief sitzt der schock noch
der russischen invasion wut ist zu hören
mitgefühl bei vielen aber auch angst vor
einem russischen präsidenten der
womöglich schon weitere angriffs pläne
schmiedet wenn der nato fall ausgerufen
wird der gegenseite verteidigung ist
kein stopp mehr dann wird polen dann
wird dann wird es riesen flächenbrand
vor zwei nach zehn jahren ist die hitler
als letzte mal ein gericht in der
ukraine macht putin nach halt so im
grunde um richtig
putzt statistische methoden zum ersten
mal erkenne ich in meinem leben der ich
nur mit frieden groß geworden bin das
plötzlich etwas am kippen ist das was
ich mir nie hätte vorstellen können dass
sich etwas grundlegendes verändert habe
betonen viele teilnehmer auch für die
demo kultur für frieden freiheit und
bewaffnung gleichermaßen auf die straße
zu gehen früher eher abwegig heute nicht
mehr dass die öffentlichkeit und
überhaupt die leute vielleicht mal mehr
darüber nachdenken wie wichtig ist es
dass man freiheit und demokratische
werte verteidigt und das dazu eben nicht
immer gehört dass man mit der
regenbogenfahne
durch die lande zieht sondern das sagen
jedenfalls auch andere mittel dann auch
ergriffen werden unter den demonstranten
viele menschen aus der ukraine aber auch
aus russland tausend kilometer entfernt
führen sie krieg hier stehen sie
zusammen sie kommt aus aufwand ich komme
aus der ukraine
die verstehen uns gut ist es überhaupt
kein problem zusammen zu sein bin ich
hier auch zu zeigen dass ich präsidenten
präsident meines landes nicht
unterstütze ich habe ihn nicht gewählt
der protestzug führte direkt an der
weiträumig abgesperrten russischen
botschaft vorbei welchen eindruck er
hinter den mauern hinterlassen hat wird
wohl ein geheimnis bleiben
russische ukrainische freundschaft in
berlin wenn sie den menschen in der
ukraine helfen wollen dann können sie
das tun beim aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe das stichwort laut der
zdf nothilfe ukraine und hier sehen sie
die bahn de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
alle infos auch im netz oder im zdf text
und jetzt hier bei uns noch mal an und
ich mache mit sport weiter in der
fußball bundesliga erzielte er bleibt
sich nämlich am nachmittag einen
arbeitssieg beim vfl bochum der endstand
0 zu 1 und borussia dortmund kam am
abend beim fc augsburg nicht über ein 1
1 hinaus und jetzt einblick und zwar
aufs wetter nach einer frostigen nacht
geht es morgen mit viel sonne und nur
wenigen wolken weiter bei einem kühlen
östlichen wind werden zwei bis zwölf
grad erreicht und auch in den nächsten
tagen überwiegt der sonnenschein nur an
der nordsee kann es am dienstag mal
etwas regen geben die höchsttemperaturen
liegen bei 5 bis 12 grad
erst wenn droht dass man etwas verliert
wird dessen wahrer wert so richtig klar
das ist bei der liebe so bei der
gesundheit das gilt auch für unsere
freiheit und für den frieden
wir danken herzlich dass sie bei uns
waren in einer wirklich aufreibenden
nachrichten woche und ab morgen begrüßen
sie hier an dieser stelle marietta
slomka und heinz wolf und jetzt im zdf
programm direkt nach uns maybrit illner
live aus berlin
zu gast unter anderem
bundesaußenminister in annalena baerbock
vom gesamten heute schon mal team in
allen einen guten abend ist